[Music]
everyone needs a little pick-me-up a pat
on the back or the old high-five and
here's a little dose of you can do it
energy from someone we love
i believe it all starts with you and i
in the mirror i don't know how to make
collective change out there i don't know
what the policy is to help uh the world
uh get along better um
but i do
truly believe that if each one of us
look in the mirror and say you know what
i'm gonna be a little bit better today
i'm gonna be a little bit more fair
today i'm gonna take a little bit more
responsibility today to therefore get to
my freedom tomorrow
um if enough of us do that that's how we
make a collective change that's the
soldiers that i think we can all be
going forward so we can have a little
evolution
have fun doing it too break a sweat
[Music]
hey drew it's arianne phillips i'm a
costume designer here in hollywood you
might know my work from movies like girl
interrupted or walk the line kingsman
the secret service or once upon a time
in hollywood looking back i would have
never ever thought that i would be a
costume designer let alone a three-time
oscar-nominated costume designer it's
really for me about
following
your instinct and being curious and
saying yes i mean my mantra is yes
being able to be open to new experiences
and new opportunities one of the most
incredible things about being a costume
designer is being part of this
incredible tribe of women we are nearly
85 percent women within the costume
designers in the film industry talk
about girl power this month during
women's history month and we are coming
together as a group to talk about pay
equity because we are paid 30 percent
less than other creative department
heads
who are predominantly male the fact that
we can come together
as women in the industry and stand up
and talk about the work that we do is
really
something that inspires me every day
the best piece of advice that my
therapist taught me that i now share
with my clients as a therapist to
improve any relationship here it is
whatever the conversation is and whoever
it is with i want you to make sure that
you are actively listening instead of
just waiting for your turn to talk so
many times we get so excited that we
just want to say what we have to say
without even listening to that other
person especially if it's a debate or an
argument and we think we're right and we
just want to aggressively go in there
and say our point but that is not
healthy and not what we want to do what
we want to do is engage in active
listening which is listening with the
intent to understand the way the other
person is feeling this will help us
develop empathy towards that person even
if we don't agree with them empathetic
active listening is proven to help
improve healthy communication and to
help lead to a quicker solution so the
next time you're in a conversation with
somebody i want you to ask am i actively
listening or am i just waiting for my
turn to speak if you're just waiting try
to understand how that person's feeling
[Music]
hi drew this is rachel montez minor i'm
an actress dancer and singer and now i'm
the author of the children's book the
sun the moon and the stars and i can't
wait to share it with all of you i had a
deep meditation practice and when i
became pregnant with my daughter
i had a dream and i saw the cover of
this book with the title in the middle
and children sitting around it in a
circle
and then all of the words of the book
just were downloaded to me it's
unconventional and 12 books to me came
that way during my pregnancy i do
believe because i spend so much time in
nature and meditate a lot that you know
that's how the book kind of chose me i
think
if we create space in our life through
taking a deep breath getting out in
nature taking a walk deciding to look up
at the
the sun and the trees and the clouds and
take a break from looking down at your
phone allowing some time that is
uncontrolled even if it's just a
daydream
that's when we can get our inspiration
we can let magic in our lives
thank you for sharing that with us